la
seconda parte di poppy bracey
rivediamo anche i quali finalmente però
che vuoi per lo piazzi supernova vedere
il suo primo arte hanno subito a vederla
e poi prendete questo video così sapete
che cosa è successo esattamente
io come sempre sono emozionatissimo
perché adoro il giorno prima che adoro
le cose paurose e questo gioco e super
super
paurosi sa cosa ci aspetta in questa
seconda parte effettivamente la prima
parte ciarcià tenuto col fiato sospeso
tra i tanti colpi di scena tante share e
favolose e poi ma milan l'ex essi sembra
ci siano sia una leva cosa dovremmo fare
si è attivato qualcosa è accaduto
qualcosa 61 spain ma sicuramente devono
attivare qualcosa vedete c'era una cosa
che stava rotolando per un meccanismo
qualcosa e di un gancio o devo far
prendere qualcosa piace perché questo
questa specie di dinosauri no per
gigante questa questo guardano ci si può
appendere la sopra zero perché 6
posso girarlo comune ogni volta che
vitale disse guarda guarda guarda
berlino abituato che mi chiamo guarda a
lui quindi non va a guardare alla
finestra e adesso inserire la finestra
che sta guardando per vedere se c'è
qualche stagione
non lo so mi devo spostare anch'io dove
lo devo portare è un percorso in una
specie di ferrovia al contrario però
così
perché poi non non prenda me questo caso
come le macchinette che devi prendere i
pupazzi che io adoro è davvero troppo
tempo eseguite su tik tok sennò mi
seguite ancora andate a seguirmi sono
vari video io più gioco alla macchinetta
con il gancio e uno chic e ma riesco a
vincere molto spesso anzi se volete un
giorno vi dico qualche trucchetto ok è
finita la strada del gancio adesso dove
prendere il dinosauro allora quasi un
pulsante
che cosa c'era scritto su scritto
qualcosa le anime sante
proviamo qua
ok io ero l'elettricità sapete che è una
nuova cosa che abbiamo in questo poi
pensa in 26 abbiamo alle lettere sica
della mano ma questo progetto produrre
elettricità
ok proviamo a riprendere l'elettricità
mi dice che il peso è troppo alto tocca
a kyoto è proprio come nella forma si
muove prima ho detto che il bravo ma
sbagliando allora avete mi attira un
pochettino di provo adesso forse
dovrebbe prenderlo per 13 a 0 il gancio
bassotto vediamo desidero decida
vediamolo ok tirava leva a noi non serve
tirare la leva
non si può ascoltarla e ore e forse lo
devi spostare con le mani non ti fanno
imparare dalle
no
allora tutto da capo no non abbiamo
spostato di due centimetri e
un peso stata la gestiva mette credo di
sì vediamo che amo stelo prendere
esposta sotto sfruttato credo che vede
spesso motivo di venire da
noi si ripresenta
vi sarebbe caduto in testa
non apparire no
salì su ok
ottimo riuscite ho chiesto l'acqua
ma vorrei anche voi bbc non so perché ma
la stop ravvisato di posto in cui
potrebbe uscire anni ma mi sento anche
guardare pauroso no per fortuna non
potevo andare l'italiano lady marian
diruti vedremo il film è tutto molto
interessante il momento buio gioco però
mamma meno glass no ai festival che si
dice convinto che fa palestra
c'è un bottone
interrotto
no grossi determinato due
dovrà attivare l'elettricità allora uno
è il viaggio ha portato su wow ha forse
su questo paolo allora anche è un po
difficile non riesco a muovermi anche se
non riuscite a salire qua primaria in
cattedra o
necessità ora devo scendere giù si no
ok allora abbiamo scoperto come si fa
devo prendere la luce da quasi
l'elettricità poi mangiarsi io qua 6
questo sempre più vero si esce di giu ok
ora uscire al fame per avere questa
la trama non hai mai
gas
abbiamo ti va male persino anche adesso
sali preme il bottone stranamente non si
è più vista poppi la bambola vi
ricordate nel primo episodio abbiamo
visto coppi che sembra essere buono ma
non lo so secondo me è buono davvero o
no secondo me è buona perché mi sembrava
non lo so mi sembrava molto carino c'era
e onesta e anche lei ha detto che vuole
scappare dalla fabbrica quindi potrebbe
essere buona effettivamente ma chi lo sa
macché
magari c'è un colpo di scena alla fine
stavo dicendo non lo sappiamo dobbiamo
fidarci scomparsa il che è molto strano
e sospetto festa ha detto che ci avrebbe
accompagnato fino alla fine ma milo un
club che l'ha presa no
vero mi ero di tutti adesso possiamo
questa sede che blocca la porta abbiamo
noi salvare può più ha detto perché
bambino che lei l'ha presa
un po inquietante testa mi dice che le
entrare ma cosa un po buffa
siamo tornati alla fabbrica vedi la
risentirsi non so se devo andare qui non
possa andare alla sera qui
cosa sta succedendo aspetta un'altra
prova di mammi raul ex la scritta via
ancora rosso però perché noi abbiamo
fatto la prima prova con mammina
homeless ma ci manca la seconda ok si
seconda sfida attivata
hai fatto un ottimo lavoro sei troppo
intelligente il prossimo annunciate il
prossimo gioco come si chiama guagua di
che cosa sarà non lo so per cosa altro
di mortale come il primo della memoria
in cui sarà quello guazzo come si
chiamava basso non manzoni ma chi cazzo
gli atti
mandare stai attenta eccolo eccolo qua e
là ma chi ho capito che con forse avete
presenti giochi della talpa tipo quello
che deve schiacciare la
talpa e giornate per noi
ve lo ricordate quando era piccola c'era
sempre la pubblicità non se lo ricorda
nessuno è solo l'atto testa che esiste
sì certo numero di porte dobbiamo
dobbiamo fare lo stesso ma con a di
luoghi sembra più per dire
è che c'è ragionano tanti
fuori tema una volta quindi forse si
confiderà di guai gioco video vediamo il
video cosa si dice
ok e dice che per testare le nostre
reali non
ci sono 18 18 buchi dice motto da dove
uscirà kimwaki hong
kong
lo
ricordiamo cosa succede portato bene
allora succede se non è tutto così
portiamoci dove mamino blacks di in
generali che si guarda regola
divertiti ha detto che nel gioco
originale
perché questo è un tempo era un gioco
per bambini poi diventato un gioco
horror grazie a manila un l'ex c'erano
dei fili che tenevano gli aghi guardi
quindi se un bambino non riusciva a
spingere la di guanti in tempo i figli
comunque lo toglierà
produrre
ea di money verde ma sembrava giallo
come avverte nome sembrava verde a
youtube sono gli altri comunque
adesso probabilmente non ci sono più ma
anzi ma milo blacks ha tagliato
sicuramente tutti i tipi così se noi non
riusciamo beccare bio mag i miei libri
fa venire montato su questo gioco
ovviamente
uscirà anche chi si fissi
e usciva che se visti mi ha chiamato
proprio zucchero
ok ragazzi riprendiamo 9 quello di prima
e rarissimi io oggi quanti rosso lo sai
che forse era chi vuol di rosso non ho
fatto in tempo a vederlo ok posso farmi
devo stare super attendo perché adesso
ci sono le luci poi dopo le abbassano
tacchi e troppo bojan ottenere video
potete tutta colpa di milano blacks la
sto perché ci faremo attenti su dove
dove dove dove aiuto no no no no anche
ansia
vero sento i pasti non lo vedo però
non va bè del novecento che si avvicina
ma non lo vedo
allora finora mi fa più paura questo
rispetto a soli della memoria perché non
vedo proprio da dove arriva adeguati
ancora non è iniziato aspetta quel piano
ma con il suo non posso riuscire a
capire
[Musica]
dovessero
forse hai detto brown
13 mesi
non va beh ma sono più di uno si no è
possibile
avere anche vedi subito di guanti che
sono gialle che
sembrava
strano riprende subito e di sistemi
d'arma e foligno quello bravo con la
mamma
speriamo girati intorno o
che i ragazzi ora provo a roma vitale
non ti preoccupare di parlare con noi e
con la triste melis concentrati ama ma
sul ghiaccio purissimo
comunque è finora è la prova più
difficile più paurosa ma anche rispetto
al primo capitolo
dove sarà allora contro un archivio
bellissimo
non lo vedete dovete qualcosa no signor
no
ok programmi one verde ecco bravo
bravissimo
ecco un altro vasto progetto
dove sapeva
è che la sta cavando bene
che paura del simili lasciato mi piace
per portarsi fortuna perché quale
abbiamo veramente bisogno
è troppo difficile questo gioco messo tu
mi piace molto attenta forse ho visto
qualcosa di
lì sopra qui buy back io l'ho visto
niente ma no eccolo
eccolo
forse sono un altro là sopra
la
q5 si quanti sono celandoli non capire
buoni 17 foto
o mamma 9 forse sono 10 il paese
vicino a pandev e 10 ok ragazzi
ritorniamo ma questa volta
momento siamo
non riesco a vederli
ok brava mi sa che ce n'era uno su in
alto
qui
45 bravo
61 là sopra ma oggi è andato via allora
l'uso
o no dove dove dove no no
ok ragazzi riproviamo questa volta
saremo in silenzio perché ascolto
proveremo ad ascoltare da dove arrivano
gli bianchi vaghi quindi sia un completo
silenzio voi provate anche voi in
silenzio per concentrarvi anche voi a
vedere se riuscite a capire da dove
arrivano
no
sì
qui
ok ragazzi abbiamo riformato salvate
tante volte che dobbiamo stare sola luce
bello ci stiamo avvicinando sistema
trascinando perché l'ultima volta hanno
preso il
24 quindi ci siamo fatti concentrazione
in moto
la bravissima
perché perdono mai
22 23
ok ragazzi abbiamo spento la luce perché
siamo resi conto che al buio si vedono
meglio voi si vorrebbe rivedere anche
peggio è ora oggetto
[Musica]
l'ultimo
non ci credo a u n'ora grandissimo non
potete capire da quanto tempo ci stavamo
provando dove sei io credo
molto british ha detto sono molto fiera
di te non
mi dire che c'è un autogol
che è successo non basta basta non
riuscite più anche maghi colorati basta
me li studierò starò fuori dal letto
dalle pareti da ed alpha beta
il biglietto un grande biglietto per
scappare dopo anni ma mi stava pensando
odiato rimanesse qui per sempre ma non è
mai troppo tardi
l'aspetta che accendono l'uso di ogni
accesso siamo riemersi dalle tenebre
come si deve perché mi pare abbiano
questo caso proprio blog cioè all'ultimo
momento né apparivano 10.000.000 1 da
una parte all'altra tutti che
vedremo il conto stavamo facendo curante
guardate questione del grappa che
sicuramente qualche giocatore o qualche
altra persona che se ho provato prigione
finita male cioè incredibile abbiamo
affrontato da di wadi di tutti i colori
non lo chiamo così al colore preferito
alla scrivete nei commenti qual è la
guardi che vi è piaciuto di più qual è
il vostro colore preferito di addio a
chi vive il mio rosso
verde mi ha sorpreso invece è affetta un
momento la banca un pezzo di scala qui
è riuscita
no ma dove siamo aspetta non farmi
capire adesso è
tutto ok
ok
roma spa risalto a ciò la salma l'asso o
non la lascia
sbagliata marcata riproviamo beh ce la
puoi fare perché forse ho capito devo
lasciare andare subito appena arrivo
a brescia
non muoverà attenderlo tenere però dopo
aver affrontato anche i maghi di tutti i
colori potra fare quattro mesi
c'è scritto premi il bottone per darmi
delle caramelle giorni prima che
prevedono e non sarebbe il bottone che
vorrebbe evitare circolato in problemi e
ora che questo aspetterò dei decorati
che le prove sono tre non solo due qui
si aspetterà un'altra prova che per
questo era così difficile
sarà impossibile poi ovviamente dovevo
riuscire a scappare e forse dovremmo
anche affrontare bambino
dove stiamo andando siamo arrivati al
treno davvero queste sono le rotaie è
quindi forse possiamo scappare da qua e
aspetta un momento mi ricorda qualcosa
questa strada la mi dire non mi dire
sera ti ricordi quando ci siamo cacciati
prima quindi non dobbiamo andare qua
dobbiamo andare e come siano porta
chiesa prima sono a noi spesso si o no
o no
dovevo fare il
patrimonio messo questi mesi no non
aprire non aprire quello prima no no non
mi fa guardando la leva sta guardando la
leva no non prenderla no no no no no
fermo tempo the master fatto no
io
dovevo scappare si sta aprendo che lo
bello se ne sta andando
ci sto aiutando
chi si mise una nostra alleata
non si sa non ne sarei così sicuro e
quella c1 e mangiare ci ha fatto passare
prova da facilità di pasca tornato
libero donati coppi è una nostra alleata
chi seguissimo nella nostra alleata è
una cascata di strano noi noi che ci
stanno tutti ingannandolo vediamo
la prima di facebook ma forse da questa
passati a vederla
ehi ma dove vivi
e adesso
possiamo passare qui sotto questa
risotto
si è chiuso cancello non mi dire che che
si fissi come dire che mille qui dove
stiamo finendo ei ma che succede se
dobbiamo tradire quarto però in mezzo ai
giocattoli ma forse bisognava
[Musica]
questo
non funziona questo pulsante la storia
si fa sempre più intrigante e prendiamo
l'elettricità da qua e attiviamo questo
si apre quello poi torno indietro per
rendere l'esplicita è attiva anche
davvero bravo pensano infatti non
funziona ok ragazzi continuerò a tutto
nella terza parte perché questo video di
una tantissimo tanto sentiamo arrivati
hanno
lasciato proprio grazie permettere ai
continui ora vi lasciamo a patto che
servì che pubblicare per vedere inoltre
altri video carne su quello che
preferite io vado a mangiare
[Musica]